منذ احتلال الضفه الغربيه عام 67 كانت
الخليل في جنوب الضفه من ابرز اهداف مخطط
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي والنتيجه اليوم ان
بالخليل اكثر من 30 مستوطنه و20 بؤره
استيطانيا تعد مستوطنه كريات اربع التي
انشئ عام 68 ابرز مثال على اهميه الخليل
في المخطط الاستيطاني الاسرائيلي هي اليوم
ليست فقط واحده من اكبر المستوطنات بل
انها مقر لتنظيم ما اسرائيليه متطرفه لها
كلمه في السياسه
الاسرائيليه كان الهدف الابرز منذ البدايه
هو البلده القديمه للخليل حيث الحرم
الابراهيمي الذي طوق بعدد من البؤر
الاستيطانيه بدا ان هناك رغبه لتضييق
الخناق على الفلسطينيين لارغام على مغادره
البلده القديمه في عام 97 وبعد توقيع
اتفاق اصل توصلت منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل الى بروتوكول قسمت بموجبه مدينه
الخليل الى منطقتين اتش واح واتش اان يعيش
في منطقه اتش اان اليوم نحو 700 مستوطن
400 بشكل دائم و300 يدرسون في مدرسه دينيه
ومن اجلهم اعطيت الصلاحيات الامنيه
لاسرائيل عند توقيع بروتوكول 97 كان يعيش
في البلده القديمه نحو 35000 فلسطيني
اليوم تراجع عددهم بشكل كبير بسبب
المضايقات واغلاق المحال التجاريه وصعوبه
التنقل واستفزازات المستوطنين ترى منظمه
بتسيلم الاسرائيليه ان اسرائيل وضعت نظام
فصل عنصري في الخليل حيث اقيمت عشرات
الحواجز الامنيه وقطعت اوصال مناطق سكن
الفلسطينيين وتحولت البلده القديمه الى
منطقه محاصره يتحرك فيها سكانها بصعوبه
شديده في عام 94 نفذ الارهابي باروخ
جولدشتاين مجزره في الحرم الابراهيمي
استشهد خلالها 29 مصليا لم يك هذا
الاعتداء الاول او الاخير على الفلسطينيين
في الخليل بعد المجزره قررت اسرائيل تقسيم
الحرم الابراهيمي زمانيا ومكانيا وخصصت
نحو 60 في من الحرم للاسرائيليين وسمحت
لهم باستخدام كامل المسجد خلال عشره ايام
ليستمر مخطط تهويد الخليل عبر
الاستيطان